be nice to Skylar's backstage here's  what's great it's the first season  Leah's so we bought a lot of money so  apparently we can only snow in certain  place it's so funny because I have a  funny story I when I was on Glee I did a  song from frozen and we had the fake  snow and it was like really heavy and I  looked up during so song being like wow  this is a lot of snow and choked on the  fake snow that's funny I loved the  performance and then it got really messy  and we were filming in slow-mo and they  got the entire thing on camera if you  know what I mean  so my sympathy is just this is a lot I  have choked off a tostone of performance  before this meeting a thing for singers  not even careful you got to get it out  of the mouth weight of the mouth I will  not stop talking until you subscribe to  my youtube channel that's right and I  could talk a lot seriously not gonna  stop yep still here not going anywhere I  see you don't walk away from this